[Musique]
c'est sous le préau de l'école primaire
de la chaumière à saint denis que ces
petits accueille en chansons le
secrétaire d'état chargé de l'enfance et
des familles pour sa première journée de
déplacement sur l'île
adrien taquet a visité une classe
passerelle dans cette école
un dispositif qui permet d'accueillir
les enfants dès l'âge de 2 ans tout en
proposant un soutien à la parentalité
tous les jours ici dans cette salle
une dizaine d'enfants fait
l'apprentissage de l'école accompagnés
de leurs parents
petit groupe
propose aussi des moments on
le secrétaire d'état s'est ensuite rendu
au centre de protection maternelle et
infantile de plateau caillou pour signer
une convention sur la petite enfance et
le soutien à la parentalité
les partenaires présents engageront 10
millions d'euros supplémentaires afin
d'améliorer la prise en charge et
l'accompagnement des enfants en
situation préoccupante
1 investir dans les pme on y revient
parce que une fois encore je veux en
faire un peu la pierre angulaire de la
politique globale de prévention
notamment pour qu'elles puissent
réaliser plus encore de bilan d'école
maternelle plus encore d'entretien
prénataux précoce puisque ça fait partie
des choses que nous avons évoqué les
deuxièmement l'accompagnement ou
l'évoqué madame la directrice des
enfants en situation de handicap de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance des mesures
dette sociale à l'enfance qui vise à
accentuer la prévention avant
d'envisager les mesures de placement et
de donner les mêmes chances
d'épanouissement à tous les enfants
[Musique]